hello and welcome to the point now as
you know I like to use this show to talk
about the things that interest me and
might interest you but unfortunately
this week the thing I want to talk about
well not allowed to
[Music]
if you're watching this video the
chances are you familiar with the term
embargo it comes up every time you're
waiting for a new game to be reviewed or
streamed but frequently I come across a
lot of misunderstanding about the nature
of embargoes the types of restrictions
they impose and the reasons they exist
so this week on the point I gonna shine
a light on Press embargoes what they are
where they've come from and when you as
consumers of media should be skeptical
of them
[Music]
you
press embargoes come in all shapes and
sizes but most of them are pretty
standard in the games press Fiat sites
like GameSpot youtubers mercenaries or
streamers they usually come in two forms
preview embargoes and review embargoes
reviews are the most common were given
early access to a game with the
condition that the review can't be
posted before a particular date and time
usually a day or two before the game's
release there are hardly ever any
restrictions on the content of the
review though sometimes they ask that
you stick away from spoilers
however preview embargoes are usually a
bit more involved they include the usual
date and time restrictions on top of a
number of restrictions around what you
can and cannot talk about usually you
have to stick to talking about certain
levels and mechanics as games are often
full of work-in-progress elements that
the normies would rather you not talk
about to be involved in previews you
usually have to sign an NDA or a
non-disclosure agreement which documents
that you agree to such restrictions in
your reporting so embargoes and ndas are
not meant to restrict what you're
allowed to say in terms of your opinion
on the game they simply restrict when
you can post your thoughts and in the
case of previews the parts of the game
that the developers are willing to show
Outsiders openly at least that's how
it's supposed to work but the reality is
that the wonderful world of video games
coverage is full of stories of when it
all went wrong I currently have a friend
who is an entertainment embargo
releasing this weekend for something he
saw over a year ago
while another major publisher once sent
a friend of mine a letter saying that
they could only have a copy of a
triple-a game if when they weren't
playing if it was stored in a sealed
container with an eyesight of somebody
24/7 the penalty for not following this
embargo was a million dollar fine now it
likely wouldn't get held up in chorus
but yes
PR people are more than capable of being
ridiculous when it comes to embargoes
but why do embargoes even exist while
first of all because they can if
somebody is willing to allow you to play
their game for the first time but only
if you promise not to tell anyone for a
week that's an offer you can either take
or leave say ok and abide by that rule
or say no and watches a caravan of your
competitors of the exciting news story
so I guess more importantly why do
publishers use in partners why not show
their game to everyone and just a letter
to post their thoughts whenever they
want well the reasons for this are
numerous and pretty bureaucratic firstly
in the case of previews fewer people are
usually shopping the game around
numerous
people across a white press tour often
across continents so the embargo date
ensures that every smooth-skinned gets
to post their story at the same time
this not only simplifies workflow for
the PR people but it also treats all the
outlets fairly and this also solves
another problem a problem that the press
has itself in the world of reporting
whoever gets the story published first
gets the most traffic so there's a
massive incentive to get a story and
early be that news previews or a review
and what we'd like to assume that all
people and publications would make sure
to take the time to report on something
properly the reality is that mercenaries
we just post any old crap embargo sort
of save the press from itself
you see games take a long time to finish
that's why they're sent out in advance
with embargoes a few days before the
game's launch this is to make sure that
the reviewer has adequate time to review
the game without the pressure of trying
to be first to price so that's why large
open world games let's say might be sent
out over a week ahead of their release
that's not to say that all embargoes are
innocent they can most certainly be used
to influence those with influence it's
not right buddy a lot of fall out
in this office there was a time when
exclusive paid for reviews were common
but thankfully the pressure of consumer
criticism is all but wiped those out and
while review embargoes lived a day or
two before the game comes out some don't
drop until the release date itself and
while you can't always attribute quality
to this there's enough anecdotal
evidence out there to suggest that when
a publisher has a late embargo they're
probably scared of bad reviews last year
the reviews for Assassin's Creed unity
had an embargo that lifted 5 hours after
the game was available on store shelves
a ridiculous embargo that many have
attributed to concerns that Ubisoft may
have had with negative word-of-mouth
especially considering the technical
problems that game had while perhaps the
most egregious version of this being
when I das allowed anyone who gave Tomb
Raider or Arkham Asylum a high score to
post their reviews early anyone who
didn't had to wait while on the flipside
when a publisher allows you to post a
review of their game a week before
release there's a pretty good chance
there for your confidence
I bet the game's quality now you can
follow most of this on their general
professional courtesy but there are
methods by which embargo access can be
used as a weapon the worst of which is
called black listing this is when
publishers don't allow sir
and individuals or publications access
to a game because of unfavorable
reporting in the past essentially using
the carrot on a stick of access to
dissuade wastelanders from writing
negative previews that meit's life of
pre-orders or reviews that might harm
sales and while publishers would rarely
risk blacklisting large publications or
youtubers for the obvious backlash that
would create this is a para that I've
often seen twist the arms of
up-and-coming names in the industry
smaller sites and streamers more and
more PR teams are reaching out to vocal
fans of their games to be evangelists
for these titles essentially cherry
picking positive voices from the
community and ignoring dissenting ones
to ensure a wave of positive preview
coverage it's done in the guise of
community engagement but it's
essentially a mechanism that scares
people away from talking negatively
about a game for fear of not being
invited to the next big thing so back to
the original question what are embargoes
well the vast majority of the time
they're benign and harmless agreements
on when somebody can talk about a game
they've had early access to but they do
have the capacity to be used to
influence those weak-willed among us
those people who care more about getting
the big story than being honest with the
public so it's up to those of us who are
fortunate enough to get to play these
games early to be as honest as possible
and it's up to folks like you consumers
of media to champion trustworthy voices
and be critical of critics because
embargoes embargoes
that's how up why'd you do that
people are gonna be really angry or
they're gonna like it
you